hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
in 2016 a large amount of bitcoin was
stolen from an exchange the event was
considered as one of the biggest
mysteries in crypto but who stole the
money and where were they
some answers would come in february of
2022 when a new york-based former forbes
contributor turned amateur rapper as
seen here and her husband were just
arrested and charged with stealing 4.6
billion dollars in bitcoin
this morning the justice department
announcing the largest single seizure of
funds in the department's history
recovering billions of dollars in
missing bitcoin this story has
everything right you have a big hack you
have a big theft you have a very
colorful couple at the center of all of
this this is a bizarre story so sit back
relax and enjoy as we take a ride
through the blockchain to chase down a
married couple's attempt at a
multi-billion dollar heist
you are watching cold fusion tv
the story starts with the place that the
bitcoin was stolen from bitfinex
since its founding in 2012 the bitfinex
exchange has had a shady history
from hacks to covering up losses being
unable to find banks and fines by the
cftc were all par for the course
but the biggest disaster happened in
2016 when their hong kong exchange was
hacked
almost 120 000 bitcoin was stolen
directly from users wallops
it was pandemonium withdrawals were
halted and trading was stopped
once the news of the hack spread bitcoin
dropped by over 20 percent to be clear
it wasn't the bitcoin blockchain that
was hacked but just the bitfinex
exchange where people traded bitcoin
as a reaction to the hack bitfinex
customers had their balance reduced by
36
and would receive tokens in proportion
to their loss
the crypto community was on the case
everyone was curious as to who the
hackers were but it would take a number
of years to finally track them down
details of exactly how the hack happened
i'm 100 clear yet even after all of
these years but one of the lead theories
is something like this the hack was
possible because bitfinex was using a
third-party service called bitgo to
secure its users wallets it was bitgo
servers that got hacked and the hacker
ordered the system to send all the
bitcoin to an account of their choosing
for years after the hack the crypto
community had a hawk eye on the
movements of the stolen coins through
the blockchain everybody could see where
the coins were going but nobody knew who
the owners of the coins were
before long these coins became banned
and blacklisted from other crypto
exchanges all over the blockchain
this meant that the hackers couldn't
convert the bitcoin into fiat currency
they needed another way
25 000 coins out of the 120 000 or about
21 of them were shuffled around in a
complex laundering process
the coins were split into tiny pieces
and exchanged for other cryptocurrencies
and spread around bizarrely some of the
purchases included gift cards for uber
walmart and playstation some of the
laundered bitcoin was even used to buy
some gold and nfts it was all very
curious some keen blockchain analysts
think that other parts of the stolen
bitcoin were paid to a so-called cash
out service on the dark net
this is where a user would pay someone
on the dark net with bitcoin the user
would receive an equivalent amount of
cash minus a fee that was put in a
vacuum sealed bag and left in a secret
location
the user would then be given the exact
gps coordinates as to where to pick it
up
as for the rest of the stolen bitcoin it
just sat there for another 4.5 years due
to all of the blacklisting it was too
risky to move there were just too many
eyes on it
that was until august of 2021 when
suddenly 760 million dollars moved from
the original hacker's wallet to a new
crypto wallet
it looked like the perpetrators had
finally gotten tired of sitting on the
coins and they wanted to make a run for
it they used a complicated method of
transactions that split the coins up
into many pieces but eventually all of
the coin movements landed them back into
the same wallet
it was a very interesting development
the movements of funds alerted the
authorities and the chase was on
[Music]
with special tools like elliptic the
complicated movement of coins was
tracked
after an investigation it was found that
the crypto wallet belonged to 34 year
old startup founder ilya lichtenstein
liechtenstein and his wife heather
morgan aged 31 allegedly conspired to
launder the money according to the
department of justice
authorities managed to link the stolen
coins to crypto exchange accounts owned
under the couple's names
so who were these two
now this is where things get really
interesting ironic and just downright
bizarre
liechtenstein was a russian us national
he grew up in chicago and attended the
university of wisconsin according to
those who knew him he was described as
quiet and observant but he had a guarded
wall around him
while liechtenstein was a co-founder of
a blockchain startup since the arrest
most of the focus has been on his wife
heather morgan
and if you don't know about me i'm a
serial software entrepreneur who started
multiple successful companies
one is a multi-million dollar profitable
one that i started by myself when i was
23. she's a former forbes contributor
who ironically wrote articles on how to
protect your business against cyber
criminals and talked with crypto
exchange owners on how to prevent fraud
she even did a cyber security talk with
bitgo which was the very same third
party platform that failed to protect
the bitfinex wallets during the hack but
that was only the start of the weirdness
morgan who calls herself the crocodile
of wall street was actually making a
name for herself on social media
she was an amateur rapper by the name
razil khan a name she came up with that
was supposed to be a reference to
genghis khan
but quote with more pizazz
her music videos tick tocks and rapping
can only be described as fit for north
korean torture i'm sorry
not a peacemaker bring the energy
goofy as her social media posts were it
seemed like she had a skill for social
engineering she gave a seminar in 2019
about how to socially engineer yourself
into anything
tips included while at an event pretend
to use your phone to call a fake friend
while you're doing this eavesdrop in on
important names to gain entry into
exclusive parties
other tips included follow closely and
listen and learn about your target name
dropping was another hot tip
the seminar description says she used
social engineering to navigate and
infiltrate black markets and shadow
economies in her previous career
perhaps these skills were helpful to
gain a foothold into the inner workings
of bitfinex's security
during her twenties heather would travel
the world and learn multiple languages
including japanese korean russian
turkish arabic and cantonese
in 2014 she incorporated salesfolk
a company that aims to help other firms
improve their efficiency when it comes
to sales pitches it was later found that
salesfolk was involved in the money
laundering scheme
heather wrote 47 articles for forbes as
a quote forbes woman and this was
between december 2017 and september 2021
according to vice who interviewed people
who knew heather they were all shocked
at the news
they called heather a nice person and
they also said that she was very driven
though on the other hand the department
of justice tells people not to be fooled
they state that heather quote played an
integral role in the money laundering
and fraud scheme end quote they also say
she had extensive knowledge and used a
variety of cryptocurrency protocols to
launder money they state she was not an
unwitting bystander
in 2019 the couple traveled to ukraine
to set up false identities and create
fake passports they established
financial accounts in russia and ukraine
and appear to have been setting up a
contingency plan to leave the us and
flee over east if things got too hot
unfortunately for them covert put an end
to those plans federal agents would
remark that the ukrainian activities
look like something out of a spy novel
u.s law enforcement obtained a search
warrant for liechtenstein's digital
wallet
they were able to seize 3.6 billion left
in that world they did this by managing
to decrypt a file in his cloud storage
account the encrypted file on the cloud
had 2 000 crypto wallet addresses and
their corresponding private keys a
pretty sloppy move
there's been no explanation of how
exactly law enforcement decrypted the
file though through blockchain analysis
authorities could link those wallets
directly to the original bitfinex hack
all those years ago
other incriminating documents were found
dark websites that sold fake ids and
passports
the couple did use a vpn but they used
their real name email home address and
used the stolen bitcoin to purchase it
the game was up and in total only about
four percent of the bitcoin was
successfully laundered
the couple were arrested on tuesday
morning february 8th 2022 in new york
according to the department of justice
the two have been charged with
conspiracy to commit money laundering
which carries a maximum sentence of 20
years in prison and conspiracy to
defraud the us which brings a maximum
sentence of 5 years
a manhattan judge has set lichtenstein's
bail at 5 million and heather morgan's
at 3 million
some people have raised some doubts
could this couple really pull off a 4.6
billion heist although the department of
justice has not publicly linked them to
the actual hacking of the cryptocurrency
exchange they were heavily implied to
have done it
since the stolen coins were recently
directed to a wallet that they owned and
the money was not split up between
anyone else it's believed that they at
least had a large involvement with that
being said this does still leave the
door open to the possibility that others
may have been involved
some of the online doubters cite a 2019
arrest of two israeli brothers in
relation to the hack but no further
information on legal proceedings have
taken place since then
others say that the married couple were
just set up as patsies it was a setup by
the fbi or another government body but
we have no evidence for anything like
that so far
so while there is some ambiguity here
looking at the charges brought by the
department of justice it seems that all
the evidence points to the eccentric
married couple
in the court proceedings it was revealed
that they had a bag labelled quote
burnaphones under their bed and a
computer folder labelled fake passport
ideas
[Music]
so there you go
that's the story of how an eccentric
married couple started a digital manhunt
through the blockchain in cyberspace
that lasted six years
the two suspects were not only bizarre
but also hiding in plain sight
so what do you guys think of this story
let me know in the comment section below
if you want to discuss this episode in
more detail or suggest a future video
head on over to the cold fusion discord
if you want to listen to the podcast
versions of these videos they're now
available on spotify and other streaming
platforms
my name is [ __ ] and you've been watching
cold fusion feel free to subscribe and
have a look around on the channel
there's a bit of something for everyone
and i'll catch you again soon for the
next episode
cheers guys
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking